Everyone likes Paul Rudd.
He might be the perfect movie star, he leads
a hit Marvel franchise, yet he seems down
to earth.
He broke through in the classic '90s teen
comedy Clueless before becoming one of the
comedy cool kids with Wet Hot American Summer
and Anchorman before segueing into superhero
mode as Ant-Man.
Rudd likes to laugh and keep it light, so
it's no surprise that he generates a lot of
bloopers.
And to offer hilarious proof, we've taken
a deep dive to bring you some of the funniest
moments from behind the scenes of his biggest
movies.
Just some kid stuff
What makes little kids freak out, in a good
way, more than anything else?
Being present for stuff they think they're
not supposed to see.
For example, bad words.
They've been told their entire lives that
some words must never be said, so it only
stands to reason that when they actually hear
one, they become enthusiastically amused,
like in this outtake from Ant-Man
"Cuff that ass----!"
"Got it."
"I heard you!"
Why, robot?
Judd Apatow likes to keep things loose and
collaborative on his sets, and since Paul
Rudd has an agile comic mind, he's wound up
in a few of Apatow's movies, including The
40-Year-Old Virgin.
His character works alongside Steve Carell's
at a big box electronics store, which gives
the actors plenty of opportunity to play with
goofy gadgets.
In this not-quite-appropriate-for-the-final-cut
sequence, Rudd interrupts a conversation to
show off a cool robot toy.
"Check it out, man, new robo-sapiens!"
Black market panther
In Anchorman, a movie full of hilarious sequences,
one of the best occurs when ace 1970s San
Diego reporter and self-proclaimed ladies'
man Brian Fantana shows off his stash of intoxicating
colognes to Ron Burgundy.
The prize of his collection: Sex Panther.
"They've done studies, you know.
60% of the time, it works every time."
"That doesn't make sense."
In this outtake, the elaborate, panther-shaped
mechanical prop doesn't work at all.
"... fell off.
It's cost me $13,000, it really pisses me
off."
Knocking a few back to the future
Pretending to be intoxicated, improvising
lines, and doing either of those things while
a co-star is angrily yelling into your ear
can't be easy, but Rudd manages all three
of those tasks in this unused scene from Knocked
Up.
While his character gets progressively more
drunk in a restaurant, he slurs and stumbles
through some Back to the Future-themed goofing.
'I'm gonna, you know what, I'm gonna build
you a skateboard and see what you do in the
town square."
"Stop talking."
"You guys are gonna love it in the future,
trust me."
"And then I'm gonna go…"
"Stop it!"
"I'm gonna go to the Twins Oaks mall.
That use to be the… Hill Valley!"
Cracking up is only natural
The 2012 comedy Wanderlust concerns a big-city
couple so sick of urban annoyances that they
decide to try life on a nature-positive, free-love,
hippie-style commune.
In this outtake, Paul Rudd tries to convince
Jennifer Aniston that they need to give up
the natural life.
"Really, I don't think we're supposed to be
in a place."
"Many apologies, Mr. Baldwin."
Role-ing right along
In the 2008 comedy Role Models, Paul Rudd
and Seann William Scott play a couple of guys
forced into community service.
All that stress highlights the differences
between the two, resulting in a fight, which
created a few unusable outtakes.
"This coming from a guy who likes girls a
whole bunch."
When to call cut
In 2010, Rudd starred opposite Reese Witherspoon
in How Do You Know, where he plays a nice
guy named George who gets caught up in a federal
investigation of his father's company.
He also finds time to fall in love.
George is more than a bit nervous, and judging
by this blooper, those traits seeped into
Rudd's psyche.
"I'm gonna tell you exactly what I like, everything
I have inside.
Kiss kiss?
Nuts to you!"
What a schmuck
Dinner for Schmucks is an odd comedy about
odd people.
It stars Rudd as a guy caught up with a strange
club that requires guests to bring an oddball
along to regular dinner parties.
His candidate is a weirdo named Barry, played
by Steve Carell.
While shooting one particular scene, things
got slightly weirder than expected.
"I was just microwaving some Hot Pockets."